Ein Hof am See:
Sylvia und Markus Buob
suchen die Ruhe in Schweden.
Sie wollen dort
Ferienwohnungen vermieten.
Viva Mexico:
Stefano Lotti und Stefano Navarretta
zieht es in die Karibik.
Im Land des Tequila
wittern sie ihre Chance.
Und Familie Tokay möchte sich
in Südafrika neu erfinden.
Ihr Traum: eine eigene Lodge.
So, jetzt geht es dann los.
Sylvia Buob ist in 8 Std. mit
ihrem Mann verabredet - in Schweden.
Er ist schon unterwegs -
mit dem Auto und den Umzugskisten.
Die lange Fahrt wäre zu anstrengend
für die schwangere Sylvia.
Jetzt bin ich natürlich
schon etwas aufgeregt.
Aber wegen dem Baby versuche ich
natürlich, ruhig zu bleiben.
Das muss jetzt ja
nicht gerade einen Schock haben.
Mutter und Schwester blieben gerne
bis zur Geburt in Sylvias Nähe.
Weisst du, wo lang?
- Du musst da lang, oder?
Musst du schon gehen?
Schon tschüss?
Ja, schon tschüss.
Tschau, Bebe, tschau.
Mach's gut!
Ja, du siehst es erst wieder,
wenn es schon geboren ist.
Ja, tschüss.
Also, tschau, Mami.
* Sentimentale Klavierklänge *
Tschüss.
Tschau. Und allen liebe Grüsse.
Mach's gut.
Ja, ihr auch.
Baue die Mami etwas auf!
Tschüss.
* Sentimentale Klavierklänge *
Markus wird zu ihr schauen.
Ging sie schon durch?
- Ja, sie ging schon hinunter.
Aber ja, kommt schon gut.
Auf und davon - eben.
In der letzten Folge
räumten Buobs ihre Wohnung.
Auch wenn der Handwechsel
für ihren Hof am See
noch nicht über die Bühne ist.
Wir konnten den Kauf
noch nicht abschliessen.
Wir warten
auf den Vermessungsingenieur.
Aber ihr Baby soll unbedingt
im neuen Zuhause zur Welt kommen.
Familie Tokay gab
ihr Einfamilienhaus am Bodensee auf,
obwohl ihr Projekt einer Gästefarm
in Südafrika auf der Kippe steht.
Wir hatten einen Investor,
aber er sprang in letzter Minute ab.
Ich bin ein Warmduscher, obwohl ich
in der Schweiz geboren bin.
Die beiden Stefano
bauen für ihren Start in Mexiko
auch auf ihr Netzwerk in der Schweiz.
Du weisst aber schon,
dass das der Müll-Tequila ist.
Und in Cancun erwartete sie
Stefanos Onkel bereits sehnlichst.
# Uf u dervo.
Tag 1 im neuen Leben von
Stefano Navaretta und Stefano Lotti.
Ich dachte,
er habe den mit drei Türen genommen.
Nein, anscheinend nicht.
Vor knapp 12 Std. sind die
Baselbieter in Mexiko angekommen.
Stefanos Onkel Fernando
importiert italienische Lebensmittel,
besitzt eine Pasta-Fabrik, ein Hostel
und investiert in Immobilien.
Sein Neffe soll so schnell wie
möglich in die Geschäfte einsteigen.
Er nimmt sich jetzt
für mich und Stefano Zeit,
um uns auch zu zeigen,
was wir machen müssen.
Ich habe schon eine Vorahnung,
habe es auch schon gesehen,
aber natürlich
muss ich das zuerst auch lernen.
Jetzt fahren wir hier rechts
zur Plaza Italia.
Das Geschäftshaus gehört Fernando.
Es liegt nur ein paar Blocks
von seiner Villa entfernt.
Plaza Italia.
In der Plaza Italia haben sich
verschiedene Unternehmen eingemietet.
Hier soll bald Stefano
nach dem Rechten schauen,
so hat es der Onkel vorgesehen.
Ich habe das Glück,
dass ich noch nicht im Stress bin
wie er, noch nicht liefern muss.
Ich kann mich schön adaptieren
und es gemütlich nehmen.
Die erste Aufgabe
für den jungen Chef:
einen Vertrag aufsetzen
für einen neuen Mieter.
Das ist jetzt meine erste
Unterschrift. Mi primer contracto.
Mein Onkel hat mir jetzt
eigentlich die Vollmacht gegeben,
dass ich für ihn
alles unterschreiben darf.
Dann bin ich einfach
seine Stellvertretung für alles,
für alles, wenn er nicht hier ist.
Ich bin hier
schon viele Jahre allein.
Und deshalb sagte ich mir:
Ich brauche sicher jemanden,
der mich vertritt,
wenn ich nicht hier bin.
Und das Geschäft
wurde wirklich gross.
Und er ist natürlich der Beste,
weil er Schweizer Schulbildung hat.
Das, was wir hier brauchen:
das eine Bisschen mehr.
Für mich ist es beruhigend, gehen zu
können, ohne nachdenken zu müssen.
Ab sofort teilt sich der Onkel
die Führung der Geschäfte
mit seinem Neffen Stefano.
Dort oben war früher eine Disko.
Dort oben!
Und jetzt möchten wir hier
auch ein paar Büros bauen.
Und eine Modeschau
wurde hier auch einmal veranstaltet.
Ja, eine Modeschau.
Schöne, junge Frauen
haben sich hier präsentiert.
Und er war natürlich die Jury,
wie man sich gut vorstellen kann.
* Reggae-Musik *
Alles anders als geplant
bei Familie Tokay.
No, no.
Currently we are in Botriver.
And we are viewing
another house in Fisherhaven
on the way out to De Kelders.
So I think
maybe between two and three.
Perfect, super! See you then.
Thank you very much, Hannes.
Bye, bye.
Also, um 15 Uhr können wir uns
das Doppelhaus anschauen.
Sorry, hab es nicht verstanden.
Welches Haus?
Das Doppelhaus.
- Also das teurere?
Also das direkt am Strand,
an der Küste.
Die Auswanderer aus dem Thurgau
suchen ein Haus.
Ihr Projekt mit der Farm
hat sich zerschlagen.
Sie konnten keinen neuen Investor
mehr auftreiben.
Jetzt müssen sie sich
neu orientieren.
Wo ist jetzt mein Handy?
Bis sie ein Haus findet, zieht
die Familie von Hotel zu Hotel.
Eigentlich sollten wir Wi-Fi haben,
aber wir haben es nicht.
Du hast auch keins. Ich denke,
es wurde jetzt abgeschaltet.
Mal schauen,
ob wir noch Strom haben.
Jetzt, jetzt! Warte!
Miika, Miika, Miika.
Aber: Verbindungsfehler.
Nein, es geht nicht.
Miika,
ich kann im Moment nichts machen.
Im Moment geht bei Tokays
gar nichts mehr:
kein Netz, kein Heim, keine Idee,
wovon sie leben könnten.
Super! It was nice talking to you,
thank you. Bye Marius, bye.
Wir stehen ja eigentlich
von der Planung her,
wie wir es uns vorgestellt haben,
doch ein wenig
an einem anderen Punkt jetzt.
Aber das ist
andererseits auch die Dynamik,
die ich gesucht habe.
Ich finde das so spannend und es ist
momentan eigentlich noch so cool,
weil eigentlich
alles noch offen ist,
und man sich rumtasten
und schauen kann,
in welche Richtung
es denn gehen kann.
Das macht es eben auch cool.
Es wäre schlimm,
wenn Tibi erzählen würde,
er breche in Panik aus
und alles wäre schrecklich.
Das wäre ein Desaster.
Denn in einem Punkt sind wir uns
einig: Wir gehen nicht zurück,
nur weil vielleicht
nicht alles nach Plan läuft.
Ich meine, wir sind nicht 20,
wir haben schon einiges durchgeboxt,
ob in der Schweiz oder hier,
das nicht auf Anhieb so lief,
wie wir wollten:
So ist einfach das Leben.
Und das mit Wooster,
das haben wir jetzt nicht?
Nein. Nein, da habe ich jetzt
noch keine Rückmeldung bekommen,
aber da müssen wir
noch etwas darauf warten.
* Reggae-Musik *
Mehr als 1'500 km mit dem Auto
hat Markus Buob hinter sich.
Seit gestern
quer durch Deutschland und Dänemark,
auf dem Rücksitz Hündin Pippa -
ins Land der Seen.
Die erste schwedische Person
war der Zöllner. Der war super nett.
Es hat alles perfekt funktioniert.
Danach tranken wir noch einen Kaffee
und assen einen Kanelbullar,
eine Zimtschnecke, als Willkommen.
Der Einstieg war perfekt.
Die ersten 4 Std. Schweden: super!
Ich hoffe, die nächsten 40 Jahre
gehen genauso weiter.
Das ist der Plan.
Die neue Heimat des Buobs:
Vimmerby in Südschweden.
Rund 8'000 Menschen leben hier, in
der Geburtsstadt von Astrid Lindgren.
Auf dem Marktplatz hat Markus
seine erste Verabredung in Schweden -
mit Ehefrau Sylvia.
Schau, da ist das Fraule,
da ist das Fraule, Pippa.
* Jaulen *
Es jault jemand. Tschau.
- Hallo.
So cool, dass alles geklappt hat.
Alles klar? Die Dame da unten auch?
- Alles super.
Ach, ist das schön,
wieder bei euch zu sein.
Pippa!
Der Umzug läuft wie am Schnürchen,
genau so wie Buobs ihn geplant haben.
Schau, jetzt sind wir da!
Ach, ist das schön.
Ich freue mich so.
- Schnucki.
Ihr Hof am See liegt in Snokebo,
einem Weiler
8 km von Vimmerby entfernt.
Ja, jetzt darfst du raus.
Komm raus!
Jetzt lassen wir dich rennen, du
bist so lange im Auto gewesen. Hopp!
Fahr einfach mal ran.
Sylvias Vater und ihr Onkel
helfen beim Zügeln.
Pippa, Achtung!
Sie ist glücklich.
Und wir noch mehr.
Pippa, jetzt bist du zu Hause.
Der Schlüssel zum neuen Heim.
Der Vorbesitzer hat ihn
dem neuen Hausherrn überlassen,
obwohl den Buobs
der Hof noch nicht gehört.
Schatz!
- Nein.
Haben sie etwas gebacken?
- Kuchen im Kühlschrank.
Schau mal, frische Blumen!
Wow! Schau mal, für uns!
Überragend.
Nein, nicht für dich Madame.
Das ist ja lieb.
- Ja, das ist mega lieb.
Zeig mal.
Die Vorbesitzer haben uns
das alles so bereitgemacht.
Alles richtig gemacht.
Alles richtig gemacht, gell!
Die Sandwichtorte mit Shrimps
gibt es später zum Nachtessen.
Aber bis dahin
packen die Helfer aus der Schweiz
noch ein letztes Mal mit an.
* Reggae-Musik *
Onkel Fernandos Villa in Cancun.
Die beiden Stefanos
konnten bis jetzt hier unterkommen.
Merci viel mal.
Heute packen sie ihre Sachen
und fahren weiter
zu ihren eigenen Wohnungen.
Fernando hat alles vorbereitet, hilft
ihnen sogar beim Visum für Mexiko.
Ja, langsam, langsam.
Jetzt spüre ich den Jetlag
aber stark.
Das neue Daheim der beiden
liegt nicht in Cancun,
sondern in Playa del Carmen,
eine Autostunde südlich.
Das hat ja niemals Platz.
Das kannst du hinten reinlegen.
Er kommt ja mit seinem eigenen Auto.
Ich hol schnell die anderen.
Der Kleinwagen gehört zum Deal,
den Stefano mit seinem Onkel
abgeschlossen hat.
Das Auto hat er gekauft
und mir für die Arbeit gegeben,
um Einkäufe zu erledigen,
und weil ich von Playa und Cancun
hin und her fahren muss.
Fernando und seine Freundin
kommen selbstverständlich mit.
Der Onkel macht den Schweizern
den Start so leicht wie möglich.
Das ist sogar ein Automat.
In Südafrika hat die Familie Tokay
noch keine zündende Idee
für ihre Zukunft.
Sie besichtigen erst einmal
verschiedene Häuser
und hoffen so,
einen Schritt weiter zu kommen.
Wie viel Zeit haben wir?
Sind wir gut dran, Tibi?
Wir sind mehr oder weniger gut dran.
Es wäre echt peinlich,
wenn wir trotz Stress zu spät kämen.
Eigentlich wollten die Tokays hier
Touristen beherbergen und sie
im eigenen Restaurant bewirten.
Dafür brauchen sie
die passende Liegenschaft.
Ganz wichtig ist die Bausubstanz,
weil in Südafrika ganz klar
anders gebaut wird als bei uns.
Die Qualität der Häuser
variiert extrem.
Das ist der Hammer,
hier runterzufahren
Ja, das ist mega!
In De Kelders, einem Touristenort,
haben sie
ein Haus mit Meerblick entdeckt.
Hello.
Nice to meet you. I'm Doris.
Der Makler erwartet sie bereits.
Please come with me.
- Thank you.
Das Haus mit der atemberaubenden
Sicht bietet Platz für zwei Familien.
Rund 300'000 Fr.
soll die Villa kosten.
For the ladies:
Das ist cool.
Trotz Lichteinfall
wird es nicht extrem heiss.
Das wurde mega gut gelöst.
Wirklich gut gelöst, schön.
Der Plot vorne ist momentan
noch nicht zu verkaufen?
Aber wenn hier jemand baut,
ist die Sicht weg, nicht wahr, Tibi?
Ja, schön ist es, aber mit einigen,
wie soll ich sagen,
mit einigen Kompromissen, oder?
Wenn sie zu bauen beginnen ...
Also, das Risiko besteht.
Und das ist riesiger Mist.
Als Tourist willst du Meersicht.
Das ist so.
Many thanks for showing us, Johann.
Thank you very much.
Goodbye, Doris.
Have a nice day. Bye bye, Johann.
Achtung, Kacke.
- Ah ja.
Weiter geht's zum nächsten Termin.
* Dynamische Flötentöne *
Zwischen blühenden Zuckerbüschen,
mitten in einer Protea-Plantage,
stossen die Tokays
auf eine Campinganlage.
Fünf grosse Luxuszelte
am Ufer eines Sees.
Das ist aber Holz, nicht wahr?
Ist das Holz?
- Ja, ja.
Das hätte ich
nicht in dieser Farbe gestrichen.
Das Holz hätte ich belassen
und das Zelt darüber gestellt.
Na gut, so haben wir die Gelegen-
heit, uns das kurz anzuschauen.
Oh, das ist aber billig gemacht.
- Ja. - Nein.
Ja, nichts Spezielles.
Also, es ist schon lustig.
Doch, lustig ist es.
Oh, wow! Okay.
Miika, du darfst
nicht aufs Bett klettern.
Oh Mann! - Das ist frisch bezogen,
und nicht zum Rumturnen.
Weil wir jetzt Ideen sammeln,
ist es interessant, uns bei Gelegen-
heit solche Sachen anzuschauen.
Und auch sagen zu können:
"Nein, das gefällt uns nicht."
Oder: "Wir würden etwas anders
machen." So sammeln wir Erfahrungen.
Ich denke,
wir haben es gesehen, oder? - Ja.
Anni, mach da unten wieder auf!
Macht keine Dummheiten!
Miika, hört auf damit!
Gut, der Platz und die Aussicht
sind cool, auch dieser Damm.
Hör jetzt auf!
Hallo!
Hört bitte auf damit!
Ich schmeisse dich in den Damm,
Miika, und dich auch: alle beide.
Der Traum von der Gästefarm
ist noch in weiter Ferne.
Dafür haben sie alles aufgegeben:
ihre sicheren Jobs,
den Freundeskreis,
das Einfamilienhaus am Bodensee.
Sommer das ganze Jahr über.
Alltag im Ferienort Playa del Carmen.
Hier in der Casa Italia besitzen
die Stefanos je eine Wohnung.
Schau mal, wie schön das aussieht!
Das sieht wirklich gut aus.
Ich muss einen Parkplatz finden.
Ihre Wohnungen auf der einen Seite -
ihr Haus gleich nebenan.
Mit Fernando zusammen
bauen sie hier Appartements.
Die Farbe ist super, Fernando.
- Bellissimo.
Wirklich super,
super schön geworden.
Wir haben die Fenster gewechselt,
alles.
Für das Erdgeschoss hat Fernando
sogar schon Mieter gefunden.
Ein Coiffeur
und ein Wedding Planner.
Wedding Planner?
- Hochzeitsplaner.
Für dich! Wenn du heiratest,
hast du schon einen Wedding Planner.
Hier kann man nur einmal heiraten?
Oder zwei-, dreimal?
Jeden Monat eine! Hängt nur
davon ab, wie viel Geld du hast.
* Lachen *
* Samba-Musik *
Stefano Lotti zieht vorübergehend
bei Stefano Navarretta ein.
Home sweet home.
Sein Appartement ist noch vermietet.
Die Küche ist auch fertig.
Die Wohnung ist schon möbliert
und mit dem Nötigsten eingerichtet,
dem Onkel sei Dank.
Schau, die Waschmaschine
wurde auch schon eingebaut.
Alles da.
Internet ist dort, Telefon.
Alles funktioniert.
Auch Onkel Fernando
hat ein Appartement im Haus.
Tipptopp.
Sehr schön,
Bügel gibt es auch schon.
Ja, mein Onkel
ist schon ein Goldschatz.
Er behandelt mich
fast schon wie einen Sohn.
Ich lüfte kurz, oder?
- Ja, ein wenig lüften.
Von hier aus wollen die Stefanos
ihre Immobiliengeschäfte aufziehen.
Ja, jetzt geht's mir gut.
Jetzt bin ich richtig angekommen.
Das ist der Blick, der Ausblick,
den ich jeden Morgen haben werde.
Dort vorne ist das Meer,
wo der Camion jetzt aufleuchtet.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob man das in der Nacht sieht.
Sehr wahrscheinlich nicht,
aber genial, genial.
Das ist eben der warme Wind,
von dem ich erzählt habe,
das ist super, super, voll geil.
Genial, wirklich genial.
Frühmorgens in Snokebo.
Drei Möglichkeiten, aber die
ist eigentlich die kürzeste.
Aber die mit "17 Min. slower"
ist am angenehmsten zu fahren.
Die wir gestern gefahren sind?
- Genau, diese hier.
Ich dachte, wir würden
mehr dem Meer entlangfahren.
Nein, nimm die zur Autobahnauffahrt,
geht 17 Min. länger. - Okay, gut!
Sylvias Onkel ist startklar
für die Rückfahrt.
Vater Theo fällt der Aufbruch
schwerer als gedacht.
Schwiegersohn, Tochter und das Baby
sind ab jetzt nicht mehr für
einen spontanen Besuch erreichbar.
Pippa, kommst du auch mit?
Sie ist jetzt hier zu Hause
und geht jetzt nirgendwo mehr hin.
Ja, es ist speziell, muss ich sagen.
Aber ich weiss, dass sie es will
und sich darauf freut.
Das macht es
auch einfacher, nicht wahr? - Ja.
Kommt gut.
Vielen Dank, Pappi.
Mach's gut. Guter Start.
Wir sind immer erreichbar. - Danke
für deine Unterstützung, mega lieb.
Markus, alles Gute. - Rene,
richte deinen Girls Grüsse aus!
Ja, das tue ich sehr gerne.
Schau, dass alles gut läuft.
Wir sind ja in der Nähe.
- Genau, eben.
Gute Fahrt.
- Tschüss.
* Sentimentale Gitarrenklänge *
Ab jetzt sind die Buobs
auf sich allein gestellt,
die zwei - bald drei.
Das erste Mal,
dass wir jemanden verabschieden.
Ja, das wird wahrscheinlich
noch manches Mal der Fall sein.
Also, einräumen. Pipps, komm!
Gehen wir an die Arbeit,
ans Einräumen.
Ah, ich könnte eigentlich
gleich das Auto umparkieren.
Ja.
- Bis gleich.
Pippa, komm!
* Samba-Musik *
Playa del Carmen - für die Stefanos
der Platz für grosse Träume.
Wunderschön.
Von hier aus
werden viele Ideen entstehen,
weil das
auch etwas Inspiration bringt.
Das Kreativcenter.
- Kreativ, ja.
Wasser beruhigt immer.
Und wenn man nach vorne schaut,
sieht man das Meer.
Lass uns nachschauen,
ob Andrea gekommen ist.
Stefano und Stefano
haben auf der Baustelle nebenan
einen Termin mit ihrem Bauleiter.
Er ist ihr Nachbar
und - natürlich - Italiener.
Zwei Ladenlokale und 15 Appartements
werden hier in wenigen Monaten
aus dem Boden gestampft.
Gute Idee!
- So kann man das Bett nicht klauen.
Wer das Bett klauen will,
muss es erst herausbrechen.
Das Geld für den Bau
kommt von Stefano und Stefano.
Das Grundstück gehört Onkel Fernando.
Hältst du die Leiter fest?
Ja, ich halte sie.
Du kannst mir vertrauen.
Die Appartements
wollen sie so schnell wie möglich
an Touristen vermieten.
Ein runder Jacuzzi?
- Ja, hier, für die Gäste.
Die Geschwindigkeit, mit der
hier gebaut wird, ist unglaublich.
Ich weiss nicht,
was du sagen willst.
Ich hab auch das Gefühl,
dass es sehr gut vorankommt.
Wir sind sehr gut im Zeitrahmen.
Ich hab nicht gedacht,
dass wir schon so weit sind, super.
Tibi, hast du das Brillenetui
gesehen? - Ja, es liegt dort.
Das habe ich in Sicherheit gebracht.
- Genau das!
Tokays
packen einmal mehr ihre Sachen
und ziehen in ihre nächste Bleibe,
diesmal für mehrere Monate -
und etwas preisgünstiger.
Bis jetzt leben sie
immer noch von ihren Ersparnissen.
Leg alles, was in die Wäsche muss,
in den Wäschesack beim Sofa. - Ja.
Also das Konzept ist nach wie vor,
dass wir etwas
im Gästebereich unternehmen.
Längerfristig gesehen soll es sicher
ein Gästehaus oder eine Lodge sein.
Vom effektiven Betriebskonzept her
sind wir noch offen.
Das machen wir davon abhängig,
was wir schliesslich finden, und wo
wir uns dann niederlassen werden.
Leben aus dem Koffer: So geht das
schon seit mehreren Wochen.
Und bald kommt der Container
aus der Schweiz mit 75 m3 Hausrat.
Kinder, habt ihr noch irgendwo
Unterhosen bei euch?
V.a. Miika und Anniki
kommen nicht mehr zur Ruhe.
Kinder, habt ihr noch Unterhosen?
Oh ja, die alte Unterhose.
Was habe ich jetzt gesagt?
- Ich weiss es nicht.
Himmel, Miika!
Ehrlich, ich fasse es nicht!
Für die Kinder
wird es zunehmend mühsam.
Für sie ist es nicht wirklich toll.
Das verstehe ich auch.
Andererseits müssen wir es machen.
Nicht nur für uns wird es
anspruchsvoll - auch für Kinder.
Es tut mir leid,
wenn ich mit ihnen schimpfen muss.
Deshalb bin ich froh,
dass wir gehen können,
weil wir so
einen Schritt weiter kommen.
Dadurch wird es besser, und
ich freue mich darauf, auszuziehen.
Kinder, bitte helft mir,
die Koffer hinaus zu schieben.
Geht raus! Den brauche ich jetzt.
Heute Abend haben wir ...
Können wir Fangen spielen?
Anniki, Fangen spielen.
Heute Abend
haben wir vielleicht die Chance,
aber jetzt können wir
nicht mal Grossmami anrufen.
So schnell gibt Tibor nicht auf.
Er glaubt fest an ein gutes Ende
ihrer Auswanderungsgeschichte.
Gehen wir baden, Pippa?
In Snokebo
sind die Buobs voller Tatendrang.
Zu ihrem Hof am See gehören
drei Wohn- und sieben Nebengebäude.
Dazu kommen 10 ha Umschwung.
Hey Pippa, was ist los? Komm!
Feigling!
Schon bald wollen sie hier
Ferienwohnungen vermieten,
aber zuerst müssen sie
die Häuser sanieren.
Markus,
was meinst du zu dieser Tapete?
Die Tapete ist wunderschön.
Eigentlich ist sie
ja noch ganz nett,
aber weisst du, ich würde sie ein
wenig aufhellen, weil sie alt ist.
In wenigen Wochen
kommt der erste Gast.
Wir haben uns jetzt natürlich auch
mit den Vermietungen zurückgehalten,
damit wir die notwendigsten Arbeiten
erledigen können.
Diese Wohnung
haben wir im Sommer vermietet,
weil wir wissen, dass wir
mit den Arbeiten fertig werden.
Also, schau jetzt!
- Jetzt wird es interessant.
Wir diskutieren darüber,
wie wir den Raum aufhellen können.
Ich bin dafür,
dass wir die Decke
kalken oder lasieren lassen,
damit sie sich aufhellt.
Und Markus sagt:
"Wir lassen die Decke in Holz,
damit es mehr Kontrast gibt."
Soll ich dir sagen,
was ich tun würde?
Lass es uns erst machen
und dann schauen, wie es rauskommt.
Theoretisch kann man das,
dann müssten wir ...
Man kann es auch praktisch.
Ich sage: "Der Raum ist zu klein,
um den Kontrast zustande zu bringen,
den du dir vorstellst."
Es ist einfach:
Wenn man so kleine Fenster hat,
müssen wir schauen,
so viel Helligkeit wie möglich
in die Räume zu bringen.
Ja, aber ich will es
nicht zu weiss machen.
Nein, es wird nie zu weiss,
denn der Boden bleibt immer Holz.
Und die Decke
würden wir nur lasieren,
so bliebe die Holzstruktur erhalten.
Ja klar werden wir sie behalten,
aber ...
Können wir nicht die Variante ...
- Doch wir machen die Variante.
Wir machen den Kompromiss.
- Gut.
Oh, jetzt ist der Hund ab.
Pippa!
Oh, Mann!
Wo ist sie?
- Dieser Hund! Mann!
Pippa geht es in Schweden gut,
auch ohne klare Umbaupläne.
Ihr genügen die neue Freiheit
und die grenzenlosen Möglichkeiten.
Komm, Pipps! Du nervst jetzt! Komm!
Komm! Wir nehmen dich
jetzt mit nach Hause.
Zielloses Herumstreunen kann
Markus momentan nicht gebrauchen.
Auf der Baustelle der beiden Stefanos
wird hart gearbeitet.
200 Pesos - umgerechnet etwa 10 Fr. -
verdienen die Arbeiter pro Tag.
Bist du mehr oder weniger ready?
- Ja, ich bin ready.
Sonst können wir schnell zum Barber
Shop, der um die Ecke liegt.
Der hier vorne?
Ja, sehen wir uns das an.
Ein wenig Geld mitnehmen.
Oh Sonne, verdammt!
Sonnenbrille.
Ja, so soll es eigentlich auch sein.
In der Schweiz haben die beiden
viel Geld verdient
mit einer Personalagentur.
Das macht sie in Mexiko
zu wohlhabenden Leuten,
und verschafft ihnen
einen grossen Spielraum.
Zwei verschiedene Welten. Arm
trifft auf Reich, kann man sagen.
Aber es ist nicht die einzige Region
auf der Welt, wo es so ist.
Wichtig ist,
dass man einen gewissen Respekt hat.
Weil wir mit unserem Kapital
für mexikanische Verhältnisse
natürlich
über dem Durchschnitt leben,
besteht die Gefahr,
dass man gierig wird und beginnt,
die Leute
zu vergessen und auszunützen.
Und das darf nie passieren.
Wenn das passiert,
gerät man schnell in Probleme
und trifft Leute, die
das in den falschen Hals bekommen.
Ist das der Barbier?
- Soll ich hier parkieren?
Gracias amigo.
Dort drüben
hat es einen Elektronikladen.
Ich kaufe Adapter und ein HDMI-
Kabel für die Boxen. Ist gut?
Das ist gut. - Also,
ich komme nachher wieder hierher.
Hola, como estas?
Die Bartpflege
ist ein festes Ritual für Stefano.
Wie schon in der Schweiz: immer
freitags, bei Barbier Ali in Liestal.
Ich probiere es jetzt
einfach mal aus, wie er es macht.
Ali wusste natürlich ganz genau,
wie ich meinen Bart will.
Und hier muss ich eben immer
erklären, schauen und machen.
Seit ihrer Ankunft sind die beiden
zum ersten Mal allein unterwegs
ohne Onkel Fernando und seinen Clan.
Hast du es gefunden?
Ja, aber nur Zweipol, aber immerhin.
Hinein in ein Mexiko
voller Widersprüche und Extreme.
Ich habe bereits gestern
eine Zeitung angeschaut.
Die ersten zehn Seiten
sind voller toter Leute.
Ayer, gestern, 42 Exekutionen
in 15 Staaten von Mexiko.
Und dann folgt der Sportteil.
Das ist eine etwas andere Aufteilung
als bei uns in der Schweiz.
Aber es verunsichert mich nicht,
weil ich so etwas mit eigenen Augen
hier noch nie gesehen habe.
So gesehen ist es jetzt
für den Moment eigentlich okay.
Und wir sind hier
ja keine grossen Fische.
So gesehen denke ich nicht,
dass da irgendetwas ist.
Bilde ich mir bloss ein, dass Mexi-
kaner extrem wenig Bartwuchs haben?
Oder ist das wirklich so?
- Ja, stimmt.
Stanford,
ein kleiner Touristenort und
vorübergehendes Zuhause für Tokays.
Cal, hi! Are we early?
Yes.
Sie planen,
hier zwei Monate zu bleiben.
Die Auswanderer haben die Unterkunft
in letzter Minute klarmachen können.
Häuser zur Miete
sind in der Region kaum zu finden.
Das ist wirklich ein Glücksfall,
weil es für uns
jetzt so wirklich optimal ist.
Hast du mir ...
Miika, das ist jetzt
echt nicht nötig, oder?
Pass auf! Komm jetzt sofort raus!
Raus! Jetzt!
Jetzt raus!
- Ja, aber wie denn?
Doris hat ihre Kinder schon von der
Schweiz aus in der Schule angemeldet.
Die Ferien sind nun vorbei -
in zwei Tagen geht es los.
So, das ist alles.
1'500 Fr. pro Monat
bezahlen sie für die Villa mit Pool,
viel Geld in Südafrika.
* Alarm *
Die Kriminalität am Kap ist hoch.
Die Alarmanlage ist nur eine
von mehreren Sicherheitsvorkehrungen.
Selbst die Fenster müssen Tokays
jedes Mal abschliessen,
wenn sie das Haus verlassen.
So sicher ihr Haus,
so unsicher ihre Zukunft.
Miika soll seine Sachen holen,
bevor wir gehen.
Miika, bring die Dinos rein,
damit sie nicht geklaut werden.
Nächste Woche:
In Südafrika haben Miika und Anniki
ihren ersten Schultag.
So it is going to be
a little bit hard for him.
Es ist eben
einfach zu viel für mich.
Langsam, Schritt für Schritt.
Es geht nicht!
Sylvia macht sich in Vimmerby
auf die Suche nach einer Hebamme.
Ihr Ehemann Markus
beginnt alleine mit dem Umbau.
Wir kriegten gestern Abend
wieder zwei Buchungsanfragen.
Der junge Chef Stefano Navarretta
erobert Mexiko für sich.
So viele Informationen, alles neu,
mein Kopf raucht.
Und Stefano Lotti
muss zurück in die Schweiz.
Das Herz ist in Mexiko,
aber der Kopf ist natürlich hier.